Friday September 1st the layover will be
in select theaters directed by William H
Macy starring Kate Upton Miz Justin
Verlander and the lady who is sitting
right to my right here on the Rich Eisen
show along with William H Macy Alexandra
Daddario good to see you guys it's good
to be here thank you thanks for coming
you got it you got it so I appreciate
you being here especially since you you
guys just told me that there was the
premiere party last night right was it a
rager
was it a rager of some sort well it was
a good party I've always thought you can
sort of judge how the film went by the
quality of the party afterwards and
people were there when I left and still
going strong was that right yeah cuz you
don't wanna be the last one yet those
right especially in New York you'd go to
a play that stinks boy the party's like
a death are you serious oh it's awful
have you been to one of those for real
been in come on no for sure yeah okay
bad play that part and then it's but
last night can you describe for me what
last night was like it was it was
boisterous okay lots of drinking lots of
photo-taking okay we had a bunch of
women dressed up as flight attendants
that's cool okay sexy little outfits do
a bunch of hot women walking around so
it was a good party the layover where it
is about you and Kate Upton on a plane
that's right we're on a plane and we
basically are you know 27 years old so
you're at that point especially when
you're a woman where everything's
getting all screwed up right and you're
not a child but you're not really an
adult yet so we decided to take a trip
and a really cute guy sits right between
us on the plane and then we sort of take
out our frustrations on ourselves and
each other by both trying to get this
guy mm-hmm played by Matt Barr that's
right what a tough gig this is for Matt
that's right
what actually was a tough gig because
there's a twist at the end which I don't
want to reveal but he it's a closed
comedy and he had a thin line to walk
okay it was and he did a great job okay
what's cool about the plot is that these
two women are doing battle but the
Matt bars just the battlefield they
don't want him neither of them do they
just want to beat each other it's about
the competition it's about not about
winning the competition essentially that
is now what is your when you're flying
for instance
Alexandra what would be your philosophy
on sitting next to somebody who takes
their shoes off on the plane please
people are so rude
not at all people but some people hmm
you know I think that if your feet smell
bad then you shouldn't take off your
shoes right I think as long you just
have to be aware of the people around
you that's all reason why I bring this
up in case you're wondering - William is
the gentleman across the way in a very
crisp new button-down shirt no shoes
hey guys doing well he takes his shoes
off on a plane and we have house country
fight we have had arguments about this
about whether that is proper or not you
know your feet are clean I mean if your
feet smell bad
of course people whose feet smell bad
never know that that's the point right
so I'm saying why put me in the position
it's not about it is about me cuz I'm on
a ticket I'm allowed to do a separate
kind of what I want to do in my personal
space on that airplane within reason
he's got a point he paid for it I think
within reason is the thing you just have
to be aware of how you're affecting the
people around you so if I'm sure you're
you look like a man with good smelling
feet thank you
oh my gosh that's a walk off you should
have pants on men no see he's just
trying to show off his entire but shoes
up is nothing compared to the cell phone
conversations before you take off okay
no I don't think they have to scream
into the phone so whether you want to or
not you have to hear all the ins and
outs are there business deals and I just
want to kill people for them I want to
say right now we need a Miss Manners on
cell phones man it's getting epidemic
but I want to say to everyone when
you're on an airplane just whisper into
your phone or do the call later this is
a public service announcement
okay now what the elevators as well
right okay yes I understand
well you don't have to yell into your
phone but there's not an elevator seen
in the layover right there is okay see
that's the director right off the bat
knowing exactly what that is now William
you took umbrage with the Mark McGwire
bobblehead doll over there is that a is
that a is that a I was just sitting
there man that thing came after me you
sure that's not a cop I mean you're a
Chicago and right so was that an anti no
Cardinal situation so there was no
insult meant he was just staring at me
and I you know sort of said hello and
his head fall off I had nothing to do
with you sure about that
okay are you are you a Cubs fan of any
sort or not a big baseball aficionado
but I lived on Sheffield across the
street from the Cubs
yes did you rooftop it pretty much no
you couldn't see from my rooftop but you
know they hold out they used to hold out
tickets day of games so I went a lot it
was get a smoky link and drink some beer
so which is Sheffield I mean that is
that is as beautiful a spot as you could
possibly what day Kingman was playing
for him and man he was constantly
bopping the balls down Sheffield Dave
Kingman yeah Kingman reference today I
know in the ball would go bouncing it's
very cool
no kidding and you Google you grew up in
New York City correct
all right do you do you have any fandom
from the New York Yankees the Yankees
the Knicks and the Giants you know it
was sort of but I you know I'm I was
never I like sports
she wasn't it was sort of you know
taught to me by my parents which sports
teams I should like I met Joe Torre once
when I was well then I held the World
Series ring now hold on a second now Wow
what do you mean let's let's get deeper
into this story
so how did how did you meet Joe Torre no
I was I they I was in the Thanksgiving
Day Parade where they had hired me to
play Wednesday Addams to help promote
their there Addams Family show they were
trying to reboot reboot and so we all
had to wait at like 4:00 in the morning
before the parade started in this big
trailer and they just had everybody come
on who was in the parade so Joe Torre I
guess was in the parade as well so he we
were just hanging out with Joe Torre and
the in the and he was very nice and we
were kids me and the guy playing Pugsley
we came over and let us each hold the
where the World Series ring and and I
remember the kid going like I've no idea
and I still I didn't know and then I
went after I relied cherish it now now I
know who's sure Torre is I'm sure I know
so who played Pugsley do we know without
an actor I'm blanking on his name Brad
Pitt yes Wow Brad Pitt he was on I'm
blanking on his name but yeah I know
he's a working actor okay yeah
so that's your that's your your
connection with the world sir i I've
never held a World Series ring in my
entire life so I guess I need to be in
the fair giving day version I'll give
him a call I'll try to hook it up there
you go I threw out the pitch at the Cubs
game couple of weeks ago and those rings
are huge you couldn't actually wear that
I mean it would it would deform your
shoulder now where does throwing out a
first pitch rank for you in terms of
pretty sweet anything that you've ever
done that was pretty sweet I started my
career in Chicago and to be standing
there on the pitcher's mound at Wrigley
Field was well that's a bucket list
right there man right how did you do is
pretty good pitch it went over the plate
mmm I googled bad first pitches Oh Lord
yes they're bad there's some there some
bad one fitty cent they still haven't
found that ball yes so you've seen these
awful first pitches yeah Britney Spears
I do believe rolled one of the play
tours that Brian
why carry rolled one Colonel Ellis had a
bad on yeah I mean if you ever have a
bad one it just sits on YouTube for the
rest of your life yeah it's so nerve
wracking I practiced we were we were
shooting the exteriors for shameless and
right where I was in a restaurant
somebody said did you practice and I
said I'm a 70 feet man so in this
restaurant I said killing off 70 feet
and we start
to throw this baseball restaurant right
they invited us to go outside there you
go it worked out I want to take a
60-second break we come back we'll talk
about other projects that folks have
fell in love with both of you for that's
coming up next with William H Macy an
alexandra daddario in 60 seconds with
Jay Mohr and also Michael Irvin still to
come on the program
the layover available now exclusively on
DirecTV and then on Friday September
first opens in select theaters on VOD
starring Alexandra Daddario is here in
studio along with the director william h
Macy on the program William what what
which is your favorite character that
you've played I know you've done it all
you've done Mamet plays you've done
Mamet movies if I could say the one one
character that you enjoyed doing the
most in your career which character
would that be I guess the most
successful ones I love shameless I love
Frank Gallagher very intelligent fellow
you know misunderstood
Jerry Lundegaard boy that was I love
that character when you first saw that
script of Fargo what did you think it's
great I must have it
I thought I thought this is a an
extraordinary film it's going to this is
a career changer I absolutely know it
and how did you get the gig
how did that happen for you the
severance I went in and they said that's
really good you want to read for Jerry
Lundegaard I said yeah and I went out in
the hall and I said it's really good you
want to come back tomorrow and I said
yeah and I was up all night learned the
whole script and he said this is really
good and then I found out they were in
New York so I flew to New York on the
United I'm uh huh
and and I got the port and you got the
part I had this little cabin in Vermont
where I used to go to when I was in New
York City actor and I was up there when
the phone rang I had gotten the role of
my lifetime and there was no one there
and there's it's a mile and a half to
the neighbors I was just running around
screaming couldn't nobody yourself or no
kidding sort of like The Shining in a
way just did you or you were but you
always think good memory is good no it's
about you worried that you were always
the caretaker of Jerry Lundegaard I mean
really was spectacular
I find myself quoting those lines all
the time about this is my deal this is
my deal here how did you
felicity me I always say mmm we're doing
pretty good March is it it's how you see
that's how you you say that to your wife
and then but just how did you learn that
accent how did you get that one down
William there was a vocal coach
Liz Himelstein I think there's her name
and I had done a season at the Guthrie a
couple of years earlier so it was not
unfamiliar to me it's it's an easy one
well I tell you after the film though we
had to have a no Fergie's zone around my
house because everyone was talking that
way and it got to be sort of a bore
right and then Alexandra I mean you know
Fargo is dark yes but it is basically
like the Flying Nun compared to true
detective what had when that script
landed in your world what did you think
reading this now you played as normal
and individual as we saw in the first
season of True detective right but what
did it what was it like for you to to
read that script for the first time I
didn't actually read the script until
after I booked the role because that was
similar to your story about getting
Fargo I was flying I actually flew to
New York a couple times and I really
fought for the role before I even knew
what it was because I liked the people
involved
I liked the director and woody and
Matthew so I didn't even know what I was
getting myself into
until I booked the role I knew that I
would have to there would be a sex scene
and that kind of thing but I didn't know
what the story was so it was it was um
it was a mind-blowing thing to see what
I was gonna be a part of I knew that it
was gonna be something good but then
actually being able to see exactly what
it was was because they had written it
right if the script hadn't been written
no it was written they were just being
very secretive about it with especially
where I wasn't Mike they weren't just
handing the script out to anyone who was
auditioning yeah well McConaughey was on
the show and he said that that he was
supposed to do Woody Harrelson's role
first and he's reading that and he's but
then he saw ruff Scully's I got that's
the guy I got I have to play him yeah
you know and then you've been in a
couple of movies with the rock what is
it like acting with the 46th President
of the United States what is that like
amazing he's amazing
I mean I what he's done is incredible
and if he does become president I mean I
assume I'll get to go to the White House
quite a bit he'll be in the cabinet what
do you think that's right I mean that's
right sure yeah with all of my political
experts absolutely I mean why not but
it'll be it'll be Dwayne and me
and Carla cugino and Neve Campbell who's
starring in his new movie it'll be yeah
I don't think Vin Diesel right you won't
have a place in the cabinet what was the
best advice
perhaps acting that you got from William
as a director on this movie I think it's
not advice per se
I think there's little things that I
probably forgotten now that I picked up
from from working with Bill but it was
really an it was interesting to work
because whenever I work with a director
it's music to my ears to hear that
they've taken an acting class because
it's isn't it's an interesting thing to
understand what Act you know the
insecurities of being an actor and the
the process that you have to go through
so no one understands that better than
bill so being able to communicate with
us as actors as as efficiently as bill
was able to I mean that doesn't always
happen so I think that that was that was
a it was a really positive experience
for that reason and what about you
William getting into directing as you
have now for this movie is this
something you always wanted to do or why
get into it I think you reach a point in
your career I mean Alex sort of touched
on it a the purview of an actor is very
small and I think if you're in the
business for a long time sooner or later
you think I want to tell the joke I
wanted to say the punchline I want to
decide what color the blahblah is right
and it sure is a lot harder than acting
I'll tell you is that right by the way
that sounded very Lundegaard like right
there yeah it's like getting hit by a
truck especially a little indie but I
like it and parts of it I thought I
wouldn't like I like a lot the prep the
post I liked it a lot I didn't think I
had the tenacity to stay with it I
thought I'd get bored because I have the
attention span of a gnat and but that's
kind of my favorite part can I get your
favorite Boogie Nights story please give
me your favorite one William by the way
that's a remote drop for me anytime it
doesn't matter where it is in the movie
the remote gets dropped and I have to
watch it to the end and Gracie did we
get on the show we have a seven second
delay you're good go for it yeah so Paul
Anderson Paul Thomas Anderson who wrote
and directed it we were having lunch
together sitting out on the lawn and
there were some real porn actors and in
the film and this little slip of a thing
came up and sat right between us
and she said and we said hi and she said
may I ask you some professional advice
and Paul said yeah and she said you've
seen me do two scenes now should I go
professional or should I go anal and how
does one answer that question I said
Paul I'm gonna leave this to you and I
left to get into directing yeah and you
wanted to get into directing wouldn't
you what what a movie man so are you and
you're going to the fight you're going
on speaking of getting hit by the boss
you're going to the McGregor
Mayweather's like coming up on Saturday
oh is he gonna is McGregor gonna get hit
by a bus yes of course I don't know
nobody nobody really knows like what is
going to happen again hit like a freakin
mule so anything could happen
mm-hmm so the thing he strikes me
McGregor
like he's straight out of a Guy Ritchie
movie Yeah right he's a character
straight like not only I'm looking for
Vinnie Jones right like he should be in
his corner with Jason Statham you know
he's got that's why he's appealing he's
completely genuine he is what he is and
then so magnificently well who are you
going with what are you going with your
wife or what do you what what does it
look No uh I think more Huffman is my
hold on nephew okay
Felicity's sister's son okay he's a
family friend and he's your plus-one for
the fight he's my plus-one fantastic
that's great
have you ever been in a prize fight of
any sort Alexandra I have not I would
love to go though now you tell me well
I'm going with more well I think if you
just want to you know no I I think you
know what I I think I
I would like to go once for the
experience and to be able to say that
I've gone I do a lot of things just so I
can sort of know what that's like
I'm not sure that I would love it though
I I think I'd be you know like oh you've
been a Staples Center here we talked
about it backstage when we when we
chatted before yes and if you think
going to Staples is just watching the
scene right a prizefight in Las Vegas
Nevada Jack Nicholson will be there for
sure right yeah is it just Vegas but I
mean it was like the Roman Coliseum
there was blood lust in there that was
it's it's a scary environment it really
sort of don't scare her off William I
mean this is you you should check it out
right you can or something about me yeah
hey I think I think I need to uh yeah
need to get on do you have a prediction
on the fight McGregor or Mayweather I'm
gonna go with but you see I was gonna go
with McGregor because he was younger
yes that is true and Bill was saying
that he doesn't have that Mayweather's
gonna beat him up yeah and he's gonna
take ten or ten rounds to do it he was
gonna keep peppering people pretty split
on there's no clear winner yeah what's
the biggest thing what's Vegas what do
you have that information I get kind of
a kind of regret is a big underdog
he is underdog yes and if he wins the
the lights may go down in Las Vegas cuz
they won't be able to pay the bills
there's a number people that are putting
some money on him thinking that they can
win yeah there you go
Wow got it all set up so enjoy that
fight and you know I'm sure there might
be the phone lines are lit if you want
to be somebody's plus-one Alexandra
oh if anybody has an extra ticket and
wants to you know no don't say that
father and Mees coming out Michelle
she's not available she's got school the
next day okay very good
the layover in theaters and VOD on
Friday September 1st and it's available
right now on DirecTV good to see both
you please come back anytime oh we got
it William
Macie and alexandra daddario here on the
Rich Eisen show jay mohr and michael
irvin also still to come don't you dare
move the Rich Eisen show weekdays at
noon eastern on radio stations across
the country and audience if you liked
that video be sure to download our app
and I'll be sure to help the NFL figure
out what it catches